l'arrivée de joe biden à la maison
blanche signe hôtel l'avènement d'une
nouvelle ère dans les relations
transatlantiques
ce mercredi 20 janvier à bruxelles la
présidente de la commission européenne
s'est félicitée de l'investiture du
nouveau président des états unis après
80 années l'europe un ami à la maison
blanche
cette nouvelle aube en amérique et le
moment que nous attendions depuis si
longtemps
l'europe est prête pour un nouveau
départ avec entre plus ancien et plus
fiable la liste un enthousiasme que
partage aussi le président du conseil
européen charles michel ce dernier
invite joe biden à bruxelles et
proposent un programme pour la nouvelle
relation transatlantique en cinq points
booth 1re manche stimuler les relations
multilatérales
deuxièmement combattre lakovic 19
troisièmement s'attaquer au changement
climatique il faut
quatrièmement reconstruire nos économies
1 assurant un commerce équitable et la
transformation numérique
et cinquièmement joindre nos forces sur
la sécurité et la pêche et youtube pis
après quatre ans d'une politique
étrangère marqué par l'unilatéralisme de
l'administration trump la diplomatie
américaine est désormais incarnée par
anthony blinken
ce pilier du parti démocrate a plaidé
devant le sénat pour un retour au
multilatéralisme
nous pouvons revitaliser nos alliances
fondamentale multiplié notre influence à
travers le monde
ensemble nous sommes bien mieux placé
pour contrer les menaces de la russie de
l'iran de la corée du nord et pour
défendre la démocratie et les droits de
l'homme
en plus des questions diplomatiques
l'union européenne attend aussi la
nouvelle administration américaine sur
les questions économiques comme celle de
la taxe sur les géants du numérique une
proposition plutôt bien accueillie par
la nouvelle secrétaire au trésor une
taxe internationale sur les géants du
numérique en discussion dans le cadre de
l' ocde permettrait de percevoir une
juste part des entreprises tout en
maintenant la compétitivité de nos
entreprises
une proposition en rupture totale avec
la politique de donald trump qui avait
notamment infligé plusieurs sanctions à
la france après la taxe gaffe a instauré
par paris